bonjour
aujourd'hui on va
le eagle on avait déjà parlé de hegel
dans un précédent audio et ja
bien pris le soin de préciser que
lorsqu'on s'attaque à un monument de la
philosophie tels que hegel
il vaut mieux être prudent eagle n'est
pas le genre de philosophes que l'on
peut résumer dans une vidéo de 30
minutes et c'est pourquoi j'ai opté pour
une autre stratégie
une stratégie pédagogique qui consiste à
vous introduire à la pensée de ce grand
philosophe par quelques-uns des grands
concepts clés de son système de pensée
et c'est dans cette même perspective
pédagogique que j'aimerais aujourd'hui
vous parler d'une notion capitale dans
la philosophie de hegel à savoir la
question du désir de reconnaissance
mais avant de commencer je dois faire
une précision à savoir que l'expression
de désir de reconnaissance chez hegel ne
se réduit absolument pas au sens que
l'on donne habituellement à cette
expression
le désir de reconnaissance ne désigne
pas le penchant des êtres humains à
vouloir être admirés il ne s'agit pas du
désir de gloire du désir de briller aux
yeux des autres ont le désir de
reconnaissance désigne plutôt un
mécanismes d'interaction entre les
consciences
le sujet de la conscience constitue le
sujet de prédilection de hegel et sa
conception de la conscience est exposée
dans son ouvrage la phénoménologie de
l'esprit
un ouvrage dans lequel eagle entreprend
de décrire et d'expliquer m le parcours
évolutif de la conscience au fil de ses
expériences
pour eagle nous sommes avant tout une
conscience une conscience qui a affaire
au monde qui a affaire aux autres
conscience et qui a affaire à elle même
le parcours de la conscience c'est le
parcours par lequel nous comprenons que
nous ne faisons qu'un avec le monde
et cette prise de conscience de notre
unité fondamentale avec le monde va être
le résultat d'un chemin semé d'obstacles
et de détours
pour eagle l'existence humaine se
définit comme l'expérience de la
conscience et la philosophie n'est rien
d'autre que la science de l'expérience
de la conscience
mais vous allez me dire quel rapport
entre la conscience et le désir de
reconnaissance
et bien c'est très simple pour eagle le
désir de reconnaissance constitue une
étape dans l'évolution de la conscience
humaine
et c'est ce dont on va parler dans cet
audio
disait en préambule de mon propos que
chez hegel le désir de reconnaissance ne
se réduisait en aucun cas au désir
d'être admiré
généralement lorsqu'on parle du désir
d'être reconnus on sous-entend que la
reconnaissance porterait nécessairement
sur des qualités sur des attributs
positifs comme lorsqu'on parle d'être
reconnu pour son talent d'être reconnu
pour ses efforts ou d'être reconnu pour
son courage
être reconnu c'est être perçu comme
ayant de la valeur comme possédant une
qualité qui nous distingue ray du commun
des mortels
c'est ça la reconnaissance au sens
courant
l'artiste est reconnue dès lors qu'il
suscite un engouement pour ses oeuvres
un scientifique est reconnue dès lors
qu'il a produit des travaux allant dans
le sens du progrès de l'humanité c'est
ça pour nous la reconnaissance
bien pour eagle la reconnaissance ne se
réduit en aucun cas à l'admiration
elle ne se réduit en aucun cas au fait
d'être loués ou d'être félicités
la reconnaissance c'est le fait
d'exister aux yeux d'autrui et par
prolongement aux yeux de soie
de reconnaissance n'est pas seulement le
désir d'être estimé admirer ou approuvés
c'est le désir d'être reconnu comme une
entité existants par soi
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire être
reconnu comme une entité existants par
soi
et bien c'est tout simplement le désir
d'être reconnus comme des individus
conscients
et être reconnus comme des individus
conscients c'est être reconnus comme
étant capable d'auto détermination
pour le dire simplement capable de
vouloir et de choisir
capable de dire oui ou de dire non
je prendrai l'exemple
imaginez que vous êtes avec l'un de vos
amis et que vous décidez d'aller voir un
film au cinéma
vous arrivez devant le cinéma et vous
regardez les films qui sont à la fiche
hélas sans vous consulter sans vous
demander votre avis votre ami vous dit
on va aller voir le dernier star wars
le problème c'est que vous vous n'avez
pas du tout envie d'aller voir le
dernier star wars
dont vous allez le signifier à votre ami
vous allez lui dire je préférerais qu'on
aille voir autre chose
et là imaginez que votre ami vous
répondre mais si si si tu vas voir c'est
un super film tu vas adorer
vous à ce moment là qu'est ce que vous
allez ressentir vous allez ressentir une
absence de prise en compte de votre
volonté
vous n'aurez pas l'impression qu'on vous
propose quelque chose vous aurez
l'impression qu'on vous l'imposent
et c'est très différent
parce que proposer quelque chose s'est
laissé ouverte la possibilité du refus
c'est les sauts verte la possibilité de
l'alternative
autrement dit dans la proposition il y à
la reconnaissance de votre volonté
alors que dans l'imposition votre
volonté n'est pas consulté votre volonté
n'est pas reconnue et en niant
l'existence de votre volonté votre ami
ne vous considère plus comme un être
humain libre votre ami ne vous considère
plus comme une conscience
autonome vous allez faire l'expérience
de ce que hegel appelle la négation de
votre conscience et donc quand vous
imposer quelque chose à une autre
conscience quand vous lui ôter son
pouvoir d'auto détermination vous la
reconnaissez pas comme conscience elle
devient pour vous une simple chose chose
dont vous pouvez disposer
on retrouve cette idée dans la morale de
quand lorsque quand la distinction entre
le règne des personnes et le règne des
choses quand nous dit qu'une personne
c'est ce qui possède une dignité c'est à
dire une valeur inconditionnel qu il
nous est interdit de considérer comme
une simple chose comme un simple moyen
en vue de satisfaire notre propre
volonté
pour quand la valeur de la personne
réside dans sa dignité c'est à dire dans
sa capacité d'autodétermination dans ce
que sartre appelait la capacité à créer
un projet
les êtres humains sont porteurs de
projets sont porteurs de volonté et nier
la volonté d'un individu
c'est nier son humanité même c'est nier
ce qui le distingue du règne des choses
choses ne possède pas de dignité elle
possède un prix et c'est parce qu'une
chose à un prix que moyennant ce prix on
peut disposer librement de cette chose
elle devient notre propriété
mais une conscience ne peut jamais
devenir notre propriété
une conscience ne peut jamais devenir
autre chose
c'est d'ailleurs ce à l'origine
historique de la hiérarchie entre corps
et esprit l'idée que s'il est possible
de contraindre les corps il n'est pas
possible de contraindre les esprits
on peut vous forcer à faire quelque
chose que vous n'avez pas envie de faire
mais on ne peut pas vous forcer à croire
ou à penser quelque chose
l'esprit et le lieu de la liberté
la matière et le lieu de la contrainte
et donc quand on ne reconnaît pas le
pouvoir d'auto détermination d'une
conscience on procède à ce qu'on appelle
une réification réification du latin res
reilly qui signifie chose la réification
c'est quand on considère un autre être
humain comme un objet
comme un simple moyen
et lorsque quand tu disais qu'une
personne ne pouvait jamais être
considéré comme un simple moyen mais
toujours comme une fin en soi il voulait
souligner ce pouvoir d'auto
détermination de la volonté humaine qui
nous empêche d'en disposer selon notre
désir
considérer une conscience comme notre
propriété s'est ôté à l'être humain ce
qui fait son humanité
alors là évidemment j'ai pris un exemple
volontairement trivial et caricatural
mais c'est justement pour vous montrer à
quel point il est facile de tomber dans
ce mécanisme de la réification
vérifiez la conscience d'autrui on le
fait tous tout le temps
dès lors qu on dit à quelqu'un tu
devrais faire ça on prêt considère que
l'autre a besoin de nous pour savoir ce
qu'il doit faire
compris considère d'une manière ou d'une
autre qu'on aurait un droit de propriété
sur la conscience de l'autre
dire à quelqu'un qu'il a tort de penser
ce qu'il pense ou qu'il a tort d'agir
comme il agit ces présupposés que nous
pourrions prendre les manettes de la
conscience de l'autre
c'est nier à l'autre sa volonté libre et
sa capacité d'autodétermination
c'est nier à l'autre sa conscience et
encore une fois ce que je vous dis vous
paraîtra peut-être excessif parce
qu'aujourd'hui ni à l'autre sa capacité
d'autodétermination est devenu une sorte
de fonctionnement ordinaire
ni la conscience de l'autre est devenue
une norme des rapports humains
parce qu'évidemment il existe des
situations ou imposer notre volonté à
une autre conscience paraît tout à fait
légitime
par exemple le parent qui impose des
règles à son enfant
par exemple le professeur qui donne des
devoirs à son élève
ou encore le patron qui donne des ordres
à son employé
vous voyez bien que dans ces trois
exemples que je viens de vous donner il
prêt existe un lien de subordination
il prit existe une relation de
hiérarchie
autrement dit on admet que face à la
volonté du parent la volonté de l'enfant
doit s'incliner
on admet que face à l'exigence du
professeur le désir de l'élève doit
s'éclipser
et que lorsque le patron donne un ordre
il est normal que l'employé exécute
sion de la conscience de l'autre est
toujours le résultat d'un rapport
hiérarchique
elle est toujours le résultat d'une
relation de verticalité
mais dans un rapport d'horizontalité
on pourrait dire pour simplifier dans un
rapport d'égalité
aucune conscience n'a de titre de
propriété sur une autre conscience
aucune volonté n'a de prééminence sur
une autre volonté
et donc dans un rapport d'horizontalité
la négation de notre conscience ne va
pas être acceptées
une conscience ne se soumettra jamais à
une autre conscience si elle n'estime
pas que cette conscience est supérieur
et c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait que
certaines personnes acceptent tout ce
qu'on leur demande
parce qu'elles considèrent au fond
d'elle que tout le monde leur est
supérieur
parce qu'elle considère que la position
leur conscience n'a pas de légitimité
mais dans un paradigme de rapports
horizontaux aucune conscience nouveau
davantage qu'une autre
dans une relation de socialité d'amitié
ou de libre partenariat aucune
conscience ne peut se prévaloir d'un
statut supérieur à une autre
et c'est là qu'on en arrive au désir de
reconnaissance
car la réaction ordinaire d'une
conscience qui se sent contrainte par
une autre conscience qu'elle ne
reconnaît pas comme supérieur ça va être
un désir d'affirmation un désir de
contradictions
un désir d'être reconnu comme une
conscience libre
désir de reconnaissance n'est pas le
désir d'être admiré c'est tout
simplement le désir d'être reconnu comme
une volonté libre et non comme un moyen
dont on pourrait disposer
alors pour nuancer un petit peu ce que
je vais dire sur l'autonomie de la
conscience il faut bien garder à
l'esprit qu'il existe malgré tout des
situations où la conscience n'est pas
autonome
je parlais tout à l'heure de la
conscience de l'enfant qui est
contrainte par celle du parent ou de
celle de l'élève qui est contrainte par
celle du professeur les il peut
également arriver que dans des rapports
horizontaux une conscience se soumettre
à une autre conscience
et lorsque je parle de se soumettre il
ne faut pas l'entendre au sens
d'asservissement ou
d'instrumentalisation
il faut plutôt l'entendre au sens de
passivité temporaire
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire par exemple que si vous demandez
conseil à une personne qui possède une
expérience plus riche que la vôtre ou en
laquelle vous avez une confiance
suffisamment importante pour prendre ce
qu'elle vous dit pour acquis parce
qu'elle vous aura fait la preuve de son
honnêteté et de sa perspicacité et à ce
moment là vous pouvez accepter
volontairement de vous placer dans une
relation d'infériorité vis-à-vis de
cette conscience
imaginons que vous êtes stagiaire dans
une entreprise que vous avez envie de
bien faire et que parce que vous manqué
d'expérience parce que vous manquez de
savoir faire vous demandiez à un employé
plus anciens plus expérimentés de vous
donner des conseils pour apprendre à
mieux travailler
dans ce cas là votre conscience va se
soumettre à cette conscience plus
expérimentés non pas au sens où vous
allez lui obéir aveuglément mais au sens
où vous allez recevoir ce qu'elle vous
conseille comme étant utile et bénéfique
vous allez à ce moment-là accepter qu'on
vous instruisent et dans ce processus
d'instruction vous n'allez pas vous
considérez comme passif vous n'allez pas
vous considéré comme inférieur
vous allez vous considérez comme un
apprenant qu'ils héritent du savoir
d'une conscience qui a déjà appris
vous allez accepter d'en rabattre sur ce
que vous pensez parce que vous savez à
ce moment là que votre pensée n'a pas la
consistance de cette conscience à
laquelle vous demander conseil
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
attitude de soumission volontaire
comme le sportif se soumet à son
entraîneur comme le fidèle se soumet aux
prêtres
mais en réalité cette soumission n'en
est pas vraiment une
le sportif ne se soumet pas son
entraîneur il se soumet aux savoirs de
son entraîneur
le fidèle ne se soumet pas aux prêtres
se soumet aux savoirs du prêtre
et donc indirectement à la volonté
divine
donc il ne faut pas confondre cette
position de soumission volontaire a une
conscience plus élevée que la nôtre avec
la soumission à une conscience qui nie
purement et simplement notre volonté
dans un rapport d'amitié il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie
il n'ya pas d'élèves et de m
d'enfants et de parents
et donc il est très différent d'être une
conscience qui consent volontairement et
temporairement à se soumettre à une
autre conscience considéré comme plus
expérimentés et être une conscience qui
se soumet à une autre conscience par
peur de s'affirmer
la peur de l'affirmation c'est ce qui
fait qu'une conscience va se soumettre à
une autre conscience alors qu'aucun
rapport hiérarchique ne le justifie
c'est ça la différence
et peut-être parce que nous sommes
habitués à ce processus de
l'infantilisation permanente
il nous arrive d'estimé normal et
légitime d'accepter ce rapport
hiérarchique entre les consciences
et c'est dans ce refus de se soumettre à
une conscience qui n'est pas reconnu
comme supérieur ou légitime que
s'enracine le désir de reconnaissance
pour bien saisir ce que signifie cette
expression de désir de reconnaissance
chez eagle
il est indispensable de comprendre que
hegel identifie plusieurs stades
d'évolution de la conscience
le premier stade de la conscience c'est
ce qu'on pourrait appeler la conscience
immédiate et qui correspond à la
conscience du monde extérieur
c'est par exemple la conscience du
nouveau né qui n'est pas encore
conscient de son existence comme
conscience
expérience du nouveau né n'est pas une
expérience d'un rapport conscient au
monde 2
l'expérience du nouveau né c'est
l'expérience d'un carnaval de sensations
imaginez vous une minute à la place d'un
nouveau né et posez vous la question de
ce que vous voyez
vous ne voyez pas un médecin une
sage-femme et le visage de votre mère
vous voyez des formes des couleurs vous
entendez des sons mais qui pour vous ne
signifie rien à ce moment là
vous n'avez même pas la conscience de ce
qu'est un individu
si bien que vous ne voyez même pas qu'il
y à des individus devant vous
pour vous il n'ya pas d'individus
il n'ya qu'un mélange hétérogène de
perception
et pire encore vous n'avez même pas
conscience d'être une conscience
distincte du monde
la conscience du nouveau né elle se
confond littéralement avec le monde
extérieur
et puis progressivement au fur et à
mesure du temps le nouveau-né va
commencer à séparer les choses il va
commencer à distinguer les éléments les
uns des autres
les individus vont commencer à se
détacher du fond visuel les perceptions
vont se particularise et les contours
vont apparaître
et petit à petit la conscience du
nouveau-né va commencer à habiter le
monde
le monde dans sa diversité
[Musique]
dans la multitude des êtres et des
objets qui le composent
donc plus la conscience du nouveau-né va
évoluer plus elle va s'aiguiser
la conscience va s'aiguiser autrement
dit les objets qui composent le monde
vont commencer à prendre leur
indépendance
au point que le monde ne va plus être
perçu comme une sorte de pâte flou mais
comme une collection d'objets --des être
individuel
et cette conscience particulariser du
monde extérieur va se prolonger et
aboutir dans le stade supérieur de la
conscience qui est la conscience de soi
la conscience de soi c'est lorsque
l'enfant se reconnaît comme existants
aux yeux des autres et que se détachant
du monde dans lequel ils croyaient se
confondre il prend conscience de son
existence propre
[Musique]
il prend conscience d'être un jeu
vous aurez remarqué que les enfants en
bas âge parle d'eux à la troisième
personne
l'enfant en bas âge ne parle pas en
disant je il dit il ou elle
c'est normal parce que lorsqu'il entend
qu'on parle de lui il entend le pronom
il donc pour l'enfant c'est le pronom il
qui le désigne
il ne fait pas encore la jonction entre
ce il pour les autres et le jeu pour lui
en psychologie la conscience de soi est
représenté par le stade du miroir
le stade du miroir c'est lorsque
l'enfant se percevant dans le miroir
comprend que l'individu qu'il contemple
dans le miroir est en fait un jeu
c'est lorsqu'il comprend que le dieu est
un jeu lorsqu'on s'adresse à lui et que
le il est un jeu lorsqu'on parle de lui
autrement dit la conscience de soi c'est
lorsque la conscience comprend qu'elle
est une conscience pour les autres
conscience
et donc à partir du moment où l'enfant
va commencer à dire je à partir du
moment où il va entrer dans la
conscience de soi va commencer à
apparaître un désir d'affirmation
un désir de crier au monde j'existe
et ce désir d'affirmation va se traduire
dans un désir de reconnaissance de sa
volonté
l'enfant va vouloir exprimer et imposer
sa volonté
d'où les fameux caprices de l'enfant le
caprice étant l'expression d'une
affirmation de la volonté
une volonté qui peut parfois être
tyrannique
et le rôle du parent pas précisément
consisté à canaliser ce désir
d'affirmation de la volonté pour qu'ils
ne dégénèrent pas en désir de toute
puissance
et c'est pour cela que je disais tout à
l'heure que le désir de reconnaissance
n'était pas forcément le désir d'être
aimé
le désir de reconnaissance est un
mécanisme parfaitement neutre du point
de vue affectif
le désir de reconnaissance n'est pas le
désir d'être aimé c'est le désir d'être
remarquée
c'est le désir d'être reconnus par le
monde comme existants
alors oui le désert de reconnaissance
peut à l'occasion prendre la forme du
désir d'être aimé
par exemple l'altruisme exacerbée peut
être une stratégie inconsciente pour
obtenir l'amour des autres
mais pour s'assurer d'exister aux yeux
d'autrui il n'est pas nécessaire de
faire des choses admirables
il n'est pas nécessaire de faire des
choses utiles pour les autres
et c'est ce qui fait que chez certains
enfants le manque d'attention peut
parfois entraîner des comportements
visant à produire de la reconnaissance
avoir des mauvaises notes à l'école
c'est une manière d'attirer l'attention
être désinvolte ou agressif à l'égard de
ses professeurs c'est encore une manière
d'attirer l'attention
et le délinquant qui brûlent une voiture
la nuit de la saint sylvestre il ne
cherche pas à être aimé par le
propriétaire de la voiture
il cherche à être reconnu
c'est à dire j'existe
reconnu pour sa bienfaisance comme on
peut être reconnu pour sa capacité de
nuisance
l'agressivité est l'anti socialité sont
tout autant des modes de production de
la reconnaissance que la bienveillance
et la générosité
donc le désir de reconnaissance peut
prendre des formes infiniment variables
y compris des formes totalement contre
intuitive
désir de reconnaissance est avant tout
un désir de distinction
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que se distinguer des autres c'est
sortir de la masse
on peut sortir de la masquer par des
actions qui se distingue de la masse
par des actions littéralement
spectaculaire
n'oublions pas que spectaculaire du
latin spectre tous ça signifie ce qui se
voit
actions spectaculaires c'est une action
qui attire le regard des autres
et c'est pour ça que parmi les enfants
turbulents on peut trouver des
véritables professionnels de la
provocation
la provocation est en l'art de susciter
l'art d'éveiller l'attention d'autrui
et il existe un éventail de possibilités
infinies pour éveiller l'attention des
autres
vous savez à l'école dans chaque classe
il y à ce qu'on appelle le cancre ans
cancre c'est le dernier de la classe
celui qui s'assoit toujours au fond à
côté du radiateur
bref c'est celui qui ne va pas réussir à
se distinguer par sa réussite scolaire
et donc à force d'entendre qu'il ne
réussira jamais le cancre fini par se
convaincre qu'il est un cancre et à ce
moment là il se dit qu'être cancres
c'est finalement la seule carte qu'il
peut jouer
et si c'est la seule carte qu'il peut
jouer autant tout misé sur elle
ainsi le cancre va pouvoir se distinguer
négativement mais en se distinguant
négativement
ils se distinguent
et si à ces mauvais résultats scolaires
il ajoute l'art de la désinvolture et
bien à ce moment là la désinvolture sera
pour lui la discipline dans laquelle il
excelle
on peut exceller dans tout
dans ce que les normes sociales et
culturelles considère comme teva
l'horizon
on peut exceller dans l'art de la
manipulation dans l'art de la cruauté
l'important étant d'exceller pour se
distinguer
comprenons bien que produire de la
reconnaissance ce n'est pas produire de
l'admiration
c'est produire de l'affirmation
et généralement le désir d'affirmation
est en corrélation avec le sentiment de
frustration liée au fait de ne pas avoir
été suffisamment reconnus
l'enfant qui aura souffert d'un manque
d'attention aura naturellement tendance
à vouloir produire de la reconnaissance
c'est ce qu'on appelle le phénomène de
la compensation qui nous porte à combler
et à dissimuler des frustrations passées
par de la gratification présente
on cherche à récupérer le capital
d'attention dont on n'a pas bénéficié en
se distinguant par des comportements ou
par des actions spectaculaires
c'est tout à fait normal c'est tout à
fait normal si on considère avec eagle
que la reconnaissance est un levier de
la conscience de soi
et que sans la reconnaissance nous ne
pouvons pas dépassé le stade de la
conscience immédiate
ne pouvons pas nous extérioriser en
dehors de nous mêmes pour devenir
l'objet de notre conscience
voilà pourquoi produire de la
reconnaissance c'est produire les moyens
d'exister
et quel que soit le moyen qu'on va
utiliser pour exister aux yeux des
autres l'important est d'exister aux
yeux des autres
faire le bien autour de soi c'est un
moyen de produire de la reconnaissance
prendre la vie insupportable à ses
proches c'est aussi un moyen de produire
de la reconnaissance
en main
de production de reconnaissance
a pas de hiérarchie des valeurs
y'a que des résultats
se mettre en scène publiquement comme je
suis en train de le faire par exemple
c'est aussi un mode de production de la
reconnaissance
non pas hypocrite
ça ne veut pas dire que la démarche ne
soit pas utile ça veut simplement dire
que dès lors qu'on agit de manière à
capter l'attention
on est dans le désir de reconnaissance
et capter l'attention ça ne passe pas
seulement par exhiber son corps ou ses
opinions sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'on s'en prend toujours à
l'exhibition du corps mais on oublie
souvent l'exhibition des opinions qui
relève tout autant du désir de
reconnaissance
on estime nos opinions suffisamment
digne d'intérêt pour les exposer
la différence étant que ceux qui
exhibent leurs corps ont généralement le
bon goût d'exhiber quelque chose
d'agréable à regarder
mais s'il fallait résumer la logique du
désir de reconnaissance
on pourrait dire que le désir de
reconnaissance c'est le besoin
d'engendrer un reflet de soi dans le
monde
engendré un reflet de soi dans le monde
s'est déposée dans le monde la marque de
notre existence
et en existant aux yeux du monde en
produisant des effets dans le monde
nous lisons dans le monde la
confirmation de notre existence
le désir de reconnaissance c'est le
désir de trouver dans le monde
l'empreinte de notre être
je parlais il ya un instant du désir
d'exhiber ses opinions
remarquez comme nous sommes animés par
la recherche de l'approbation de nos
opinions par le désir de convaincre par
le désir d'avoir raison par le désir
d'argumenter quand nos idées ne sont pas
partagés ou de nous énerver quand on ne
parvient pas à convaincre
ce qu'on recherche alors c'est à
transformer le monde selon nos idées
c'est à donner au monde la forme de ce
que nous sommes
parce qu'on chercherait pas à convaincre
l'autre si nous ne voulions pas que le
monde porte l'empreinte de ce que nous
sommes
porte l'empreinte de ce qui nous semble
vrai
et ça c'est curieux quand on y pense ce
désir de validation cognitives
ce désir que nos idées soient reconnus
et partagée par les autres alors qu on
affirmera dans le même temps qu'on se
fiche de l'opinion des autres
c'est très facile de dire qu'on se fiche
de l'opinion des autres quand dans le
même temps on fait tout pour les
convaincre
c'est assez ironique de concilier désir
de convaincre et proclamation
d'indifférence
mais la contradiction se résoudre à si
on comprend que le désir de
reconnaissance cherche constamment à ne
pas apparaître comme un désir de
reconnaissance
le désir de reconnaissance cherche
constamment à se faire oublier
personne n'avoue qu'il est en quête de
reconnaissance
et c'est précisément quand nous sommes
pris en flagrant délit d' expression de
notre désir de reconnaissance que nous
cherchons le plus à le nier
comme si le désir de reconnaissance
était quelque chose de honteux
quelque chose qu'on ne pouvait même pas
s'admettre à soi même
désir de reconnaissance s'affirme
d'autant plus qu'il se soustrait à la
conscience de lui-même
c'est parce que nous considérons le
désir de reconnaissance comme quelque
chose de honteux et on rappellera que
honte
étymologiquement c'est le sentiment de
déshonneur c'est parce que nous ne
voulons pas assumer notre désir de
reconnaissance que nous contournons
cette difficulté en déplaçant le lieu de
la reconnaissance
on prétendra alors que ce qu'on
recherche n'est pas la reconnaissance
des autres on préfère à dire qu'on
recherche la reconnaissance de soi même
parce qu'il est symboliquement beaucoup
plus valorisant de vouloir être fier de
soi que de désirer que les autres soient
fiers de nous
mais fondamentalement le mécanisme est
le même
vouloir se prouver des choses c'est
vouloir prouver des choses à soi même
dans ce cas là l'autre n'est plus le
lieu du désir de la reconnaissance il
est le détour par lequel on accède à la
reconnaissance de soi par soi c'est ça
qu'il faut bien comprendre chez hegel
c'est que l'autre est toujours une
médiation entre soi et soi
a besoin de la reconnaissance de l'autre
parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir un point de
vue extérieur sur nous mêmes
c'est ce qui fait par exemple que quand
on se voit en vidéo ou quand on entend
sa voix on peut être mal à l'aise
parce qu'on a l'impression de ne pas se
reconnaître
on ne se reconnaît pas parce qu'on
adopte un point de vue extérieur sur
nous mêmes alors que le rapport
ordinaire à soi est un rapport
d'intériorité
nous ne vivons pas à l'extérieur de nous
mêmes nous vivons à l'intérieur de
nous-mêmes
l'autre bénéficie d'un point de vue sur
nous mêmes que nous n'avons pas
et c'est ce qui fait que le regard
d'autrui est extrêmement précieux dans
la conscience de notre identité
l'autre a accès à une facette de moi à
laquelle je n'ai pas accès
l'autre est un intermédiaire entre moi
et moi
intitulé esthétique eagle décrit le
processus par lequel l'individu accède à
la conscience de soi et il identifie
deux moyens d'accès à la conscience de
soi à savoir l'introspection et le
travail
alors pour l'introspection c'est assez
simple à comprendre
l'introspection c'est l'expérience de
notre vie intérieure
c'est l'expérience de nos sensations de
nos sentiments de nos pensées
prospection est indépendante du rapport
aux autres dans la mesure où elle est
interne au sujet la prospection
c'est l'accès immédiat à notre
intériorité
mais alors qu'en est il du travail parce
qu'on pourrait se dire pourquoi le
travail nous permet d'accéder à la
conscience de soi
pour eagle le travail n'est pas
simplement une activité de production en
vue d'une rémunération
le travail n'est pas une activité
purement fonctionnel le travail est un
mode d'extériorisation de soi dans le
monde
et donc toute action qui produit une
modification du monde est une action qui
participent à la conscience de soi
le travail c'est le prolongement de soi
au delà de soi par lequel nous nous
approprions le monde en le marquant du
sceau de notre humanité
travailler s'est répercutée notre désir
de reconnaissance sur le monde
et toute action qui produit un effet
autour de nous toute action qui altère
notre environnement
que ce soit la configuration physique du
monde où même les autres conscience les
autres conscience en tant qu elles font
parties du monde
toute intervention dans le monde et d'un
point d'aboutissement de notre désir de
reconnaissance
c'est ça le travail au sens hégélien
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que lorsque nous nous extériorise on
dans le monde
lorsque nous marquons le monde du saut
de notre empreinte
nous avons la confirmation visible de
notre existence
nous pouvons contempler la modification
que nous venons d'inscrire dans le monde
et dire c'est moi qui ai fait ça
et en disant c'est moi qui ai fait ça on
dit plus que ça on dit j'existe la trace
de notre action et la trace de notre
existence
l'enfant qui fait un dessin des bosses
son empreinte dans le monde et l'enfant
qui vous montre son dessin dont il est
très fier vous montre le produit de son
travail
le produit son travail grâce auquel il
souhaite obtenir votre reconnaissance
et vous vous allez lui dire ah bravo mon
fils c'est magnifique
alors que non c'est pas magnifique ça
ressemble à rien
mais c'est pas grave que ça ressemble à
rien parce que ça n'a pas besoin de
ressembler à quelque chose pour exister
ça n'a pas besoin de ressembler à
quelque chose pour pouvoir être reconnu
et c'est ça la finalité du travail chez
gueule la reconnaissance
la reconnaissance qui contribuent à
l'accès à la conscience de soi
c'est en cela que pour eagle le travail
et le principe de la condition humaine à
savoir s'extérioriser en permanence dans
le monde pour lire dans le monde la
marque de notre présence
objective et notre conscience dans le
monde pour faire du monde
le miroir de nous mêmes
c'est le principe même de la culture la
culture n'étant pas ceux qui s'opposent
à la nature la culture étant la mise en
forme de la nature à notre image
on dit souvent la culture c'est ce qui
s'oppose à la nature mais ça n'a pas de
sens de dire ça
la culture ne s'oppose pas à la nature
la culture s'édifie sur la nature
la culture et la sculpture de la nature
autrement dit la nature et la pâte à
modeler de la conscience humaine
et donc quand on regarde le monde on ne
regarde pas le monde on regarde le
travail accompli par l'être humain dans
le monde
on regarde l'oeuvre de notre conscience
le travail chez hegel ne renvoie donc
pas à une activité de production ayant
un but utilitaire le travail désigne
tout acte d'extériorisation de soi dans
le monde à partir duquel nous lisons
dans le monde la marque de notre
existence
et c'est en cela que tout travail relève
fondamentalement d'un désir de
reconnaissance
on l'a dit la reconnaissance s'obtient
d'abord par la production d'effets dans
le monde
et on a dit également que la
reconnaissance ne s'obtenait pas
uniquement par des actions valorisantes
où utile
en excellent dans un domaine on produira
de la reconnaissance même si le domaine
dans lequel on excelle n'est pas
considérée comme valorisant
judas a excellé dans l'art de la
trahison au point que deux mille ans
après on en parle encore
et on peut bien en vouloir à judas on
peut bien l'insulté au point que son nom
soit devenu synonyme de traître le fait
est que par sa trahison
il a obtenu la reconnaissance
il a laissé son empreinte dans le monde
la reconnaissance n'est pas une affaire
de valorisation la reconnaissance est
une affaire de considération
et tout ce qui produit des effets dans
le monde entre en considération
et d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que
parfois les personnes qui ne travaillent
pas finissent par développer un
sentiment d'inutilité un sentiment
d'inutilité qui peut même se prolonger
en sentiments d'inexistence
évidemment ces personnes on aura
tendance à vouloir les rassurer à leur
dire qu'elles n'ont pas besoin de
travailler qu'elles n'ont pas besoin de
réaliser des choses pour exister
mais sauf qu'on combat pas un sentiment
par des arguments
et que ce sentiment d'inexistence il a
une origine
et cette origine c'est la non
reconnaissance de soi à l'extérieur de
soi
vous pouvez avoir le travail le plus
pénible est le plus ingrat le fait est
qu'à la fin de votre journée de travail
vous pouvez dire c'est moi qui ai fait
ça
vous pouvez contempler le produit de
votre réalisation est ainsi lire dans le
monde la confirmation de votre existence
et ne pas produire ne pas créer c'est
être privé d'un moyen d'accéder à la
conscience de soi
je vais à présent vous lire un extrait
de l'esthétique dans lequel eagle décrit
ce processus d'accès à la conscience de
soi
je cite cette conscience de lui-même
l'homme l'acquiert de deux manières
théoriquement en prenant conscience de
ce qu'ils aient intérieurement de tous
les mouvements de son âme de toutes les
nuances de ses sentiments en cherchant à
se représenter a lui-même tel qu'il se
découvre par la pensée et à se
reconnaître dans cette représentation
qu'il offre à ses propres yeux
mais l'homme est également engagée dans
des rapports pratique avec le monde
extérieur et de ses rapports n'est
également le besoin de transformer ce
monde comme lui même dans la mesure où
il en fait partie
en lui imprimant son cachet personnel et
il le fait pour encore se reconnaître
lui-même dans la forme des choses pour
jouir de lui même comme d'une réalité
extérieure ont saisi déjà cette tendance
dans les premières impulsions de
l'enfant il veut voir des choses dont il
soit lui même l'auteur et s'ils lancent
des pierres dans l'eau c'est pour voir
ces cercles qui se forme et qui sont son
oeuvre dans laquelle il retrouve comme
un reflet de lui même ceux-ci s'observe
dans de multiples occasions et sous les
formes les plus diverses
jusqu'à cette sorte de reproduction de
soi même qu'est une oeuvre d'art
le désir de reconnaissance et le
principe d'animation de tous les êtres
vivants
conscient
parce que nous sommes conscients de
notre existence nous voulons en trouver
la confirmation dans le monde
nous voulons que le monde soit le reflet
de ce que nous sommes
il suit de cette idée que la manière
dont nous façonnons le monde autour de
nous la manière dont nous imprimons
notre cachet personnel dans le monde va
directement influencé notre perception
de nous mêmes
en transformant le monde nous nous
projetons dans le monde nous nous
projetons hors de nous mêmes et nous
nous contemplons
est ce que nous contemplons va
déterminer la direction de notre
prochaine intervention dans le monde
plus nous détruisons le monde plus nous
nous percevrons comme des destructeurs
plus nous embellissons le monde et plus
nous nous percevrons comme des
embellisseurs
nous agissons dans le monde nous
appliquons un coup de marteau sur le
burin de notre identité
en sculptant le monde nous nous quittons
nous mêmes
nous nous produisons en permanence
alors si l'on veut comme disait voltaire
cultiver notre jardin
si l'on veut que notre âme soit un champ
de roses et de vignes
fond de semer des graines dans le monde
je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]